حياكم الله تستمر المنافسه المحتدمه في
الانتخابات النصفيه الكونجرس الامريكي
فعلى صعيد انتخابات مجلس النواب ووفقا
لشبكه سي ان ان حصل الجمهوريون حتى الان
على 2009 مقاعد في ما حصلت ديمقراطيون على
191 مقعدا وتتوقع سي ان ان حتى الجمهوريين
لسته عشر مقعدا اضافيا ليصل الاجمالي الى
225 مقعدا بينما سيصل عدد مقاعد
الديمقراطيين الى
1595 باضافه اربعه مقاعد فقط اما بشان
المنافسه في مجلس الشيوخ احتل الجمهوريون
49 مقعدا فيما حصد الديمقراطيون 48 مقعدا
وتتبقى ثلاث مقاعد او ثلاثه مقاعد في مجلس
الشيوخ غير محسومه هي في جورجيا واريزونا
ونيفادا تتجه مشاهدينا ولايه اريزونا
لتصبح زرقاء بعد تقدم المرشحه الديمقراطي
على منافسه الجمهوري وعلى العكس تتجه
نيفادا لتصبح حمراء ليحسد مرشح الحزب
الجمهوري مقعدها بمجلس الشيوخ بينما تظل
ولايه جورجيا عصيه على الحسم لاي من
الحسبين وتتجه الى انتخابات اعاده في
السادس من ديسمبر المقبل وستكون هي مفتاح
الاغلبيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وينك وينك
[موسيقى]
حاليا في الموقع الالكتروني لدينا
959 شخصا تم ادخالهم في عمليه التحقق من
بياناتهم ومن بين هؤلاء
5366 لم يتم التحقق من بطاقات القراءه من
بعد وسيستمر هذا الرقم في النمو حتى ينتهي
من معالجه بطاقات الاختراع بالبريد
هناك سباق في ولاياتنا سينتقل الى السادس
من ديسمبر المقبل وهو سباق على مقعد عضو
مجلس الشيوخ بين رفيع الوورنك وهرش ووكر
وسنبدا التحضيرا لجوله الاعاده والمقاطعات
تستعد لذلك ويمكن للناخبين الحصول على
بطاقات الاقتراع من الان حتى يوم الاثنين
الموافق الثامن والعشرين من نوفمبر
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
في الولايات التي لم تحسم تبدو الاهميه
واضحه باريزونا خلال الساعات الاخيره
تقارب جمهوري الديمقراطي الى اين تتجه
الامور حتى الان
كما ذكرت قبل اللحظات بالفعل لان الولايه
تقدم فيها السيناتور الحالي الديمقراطي
كالي وكان الفارق بينه كبير جدا مع منافسه
الجمهوري ولكن خلال عمليات الفرز والعد
تبين بحسب الاحصاءات الاخيره ان هذا
الفارق بدا يتضاءل لماذا الموضوع مهم لانه
يحتفظ بتقدم حوالي 80 الف صوت عن منافسه
الجمهوري وهناك اقله نصف مليون بطاقه لم
يتم حسبالها هذا النصف مليون عاده ما يكون
جمهوريا ولو بالفعل صحه هذه التوقعات فمن
الممكن من الممكن ان يخسر السنه
تؤديمقراطي هذا المقعد في اريزونا ولكننا
مازلنا ننتظر خصوصا ان هذه الامور
تتعرض لعمليات العدوى الفرس في اللحظات
على الاخير
لاري وكذلك ايضا الحديث عن تقدم
الجمهوريين في ولايه اخرى مهمه ايضا
نيفادا السي ان ان تقول بان فارق الاصوات
على مقعد الشيوخ في هذه الولايه نحو 15
الف صوت لصالح الجمهوري حتى الان هذا
الحديث قبل ساعه من بدايه هذه النشره
ولكن هناك بعض
الطرفين اصبح ضيقا وعمليات العدل والفرز
ما زالت مستمره وهذا يعطي فكره
لتقارب هذه المعركه ويعطي فكره ايضا عن
المعنى السياسي لهذه المعركه التي حصلت
خلال الايام الاخيره الحصيله السياسيه في
ما يدور ايضا في وسائل الاعلام بان هناك
صحيح فعلا النصر للجمهوريين بخصوصا في
مجلس النواب يبدو ان الامور تتجه الى
الحزب الجمهوري لكن لماذا الحديث على انه
همم النصر لم يكن على قدر التوقعات او
الطموحات حتى بالنسبه للجمهوريه
كان يذبح الجمهوريون لنصر كاسح وكسبان
حوالي
66 مقعد اضافي بمجموعه في مجلس
النواب الامريكي وحيازه ربما خمسه او سته
مقاعد في مجلس الشيوخ هذه كانت التوقعات
في الربيع الماضي ولكن بدات هذه التوقعات
بالتراجع وعندما وصلنا الى يوم الانتخاب
هم على الارجح لن يكسبوا مجلس الشيوخ وعين
كسبوا مجلس النواب فانهم سوف يكسبون ذلك
بالنسبه قليله جدا هذا يعتبر نصره بالنسبه
للجمهوريين ولكنهصر اكبر لان الديمقراطيين
فهم غيروا مسار همم الدوران الانتخابيه
حيث عاده ما يخسر الرئيس الامريكي
الكونغرس في اول دوره من الانتخابات
النصفيه لماذا حدث كل ذلك
اولا اا التضخم والغراء تراجعات ثانيا
بدات اصابع الاتهام تتوجه الان الى الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ودوره بين مزدوجين
السلبي في هذه الانتخابات اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من واشنطن مراسل العربيه بير غانم
على كل هذه المعلومات وانتقل الى شيكاغو
ينضم الينا من هناك المحرر بصحيفه عرب
امريكا اسامه سبلاني سيد اسامه مرحبا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض ابدا معكم
الزميل يتحدث عن دور الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب في هذه الانتخابات
وبانه يوصف بانه دور سلبي حتى هذه اللحظه
هل تتفق مع حديث كندا
نعم اولا صباح الخير من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من ولايه ميشيغان وليست ولايه
شقاوه
في كل العالم العربي
تراجع الجمهوريين في في التوقعات التي
كانت
في منذ اشهر بان جمهوريه سيطرون على مجلس
الشيوخ والنواب الامريكيين
بالطبع اليوم الانتخابات جريده النهار
الثلاثاء واليوم نحن يعني ننتظر النتائج
النهائيه
واستطيع ان اقوله بان هذا التراجع سببه
مواقف ضامن ترامب من الحزب الجمهوري يعني
كل الذي دعامهم دونالد ترامب في هذه
الانتخابات او معظمهم على الاقل خسروا
الانتخابات وهذا يدل لانه هنالك نوع حتى
من التردد عند جمهوريين من دعم المرشحين
الذي دعامهم وهذا سيؤثر على الانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 2000 و24 اذا قرر دانا ترامب
هل خسرون لانهم همم مدعومين من الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ام خسروا بسبب
الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه او بسبب الاصوات
التي اتجهت الى الديمقراطين والمفاضله في
هذه الانتخابات بين الجمهوري وبديمقراطي
وترامب ليس له علاقه في النهايه يدعم مرشح
يدعم بايدن او حتى اوباما مرشحين من الحزب
الديمقراطي
صحيح دونالد ترامب هو جزء من الخساره
اسباب الخساره الجمهوريه سبب الاخر هو ان
الجمهوريين همم يعني قاموا بمغامره في
عمليه الاجهاض ااا في في نزع قرار روفر
سيزويد الذي يسمح بالاجهاض في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهذا مما دفع كثير من
الولايات لوضع همم حق الاجهاض على لائحه
الاقتراع ومما حفظ الديمقراطيين
والليبراليين الى الخروج للتصويت في هذه
الانتخابات وهذا سبب كبير في هزيمه
الجمهوريه او تراجع الجمهوريه في هذه
الانتخابات
الجمهوريون هل تراجعوا فعلا في هذه
الانتخابات بعد ان استعدوا مجلس الشيوخ او
عفوا بعد ان استعدوا مجال النواب وفي مجلس
الشيوخ يبدو ان الكفه متساويه
مثلا
للاربعين سنه الماضيه كان الجمهوريون
يسيطرون على المجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ
في هذه الجوله الانتخابيه المصريه
وبعض الاحيان الى الديمقراطيين وهذا دليل
اكبر دليل بان الاجهاض كان يعني حق
الاجهاض عند المراه كان من الاسباب
الرئيسيه لهزيمه جمهوريين في ولايات ربما
تراجعهم في بعض الولايات الاخرى المترجمه
الجزء الاخر من هذه الهزيمه او التراج
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من منشن انضم الينا
المحرر في صحيفه عرب امريكا اسامه سبلاني
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
قال الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسي
بان القوات الروسيه تتعرضوا لضغوطها الى
في اوكرانيا واضاف خلال مؤتمر الصحفي مع
رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني في
روما ان الانسحاب الروسي من خير سون يشكل
نصرا جديدا لاوكرانيا
وعيدكم يعقده مسؤوله الامم المتحده
محادثات مع مسؤولين روس في جنيف غدا
الجمعه بشان اتفاقيات البحر الاسود
المرتبطه بتصدير الحبوب والاسمده من
اوكرانيا وروسيا وفقما اعلنت ناطقه باسم
المنظمه كما عبره المتحدثه عن املها بان
تدفع المحادثات باتجاه التقدم الذي تحقق
حتى الان في تسهيل عمليات تصدير الاغذيه
والاسمده من روسيا الى الاسواق الدوليه
دون عوائق
اليوم في الرياضه اعماله المنتدى الدولي
للامن السبراني بعد مشاركه واسعه للمهتمين
بهذا المجاري الحيوي الذين يمثلون اكثر من
100 دوله المنتدى شهد حضوره عالميه سياسيه
بارزه كما حضر الجلسات الحواريه وزير
الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان ووزير الاتصالات وتقنيه المعلومات
المهندس عبد الله السواحد
قاده سياسيون وخبراء في الامن السيبراني
من حول العالم اجتمعوا في المنتدى الدولي
للامن السيبراني في نسخته الثانيه الحضور
الكثيف من المهتمين والمختصين في دول
العالم يوضح الاهتمام الدولي بتعزيز الامن
السيبراني خاصه في قطاعات الطاقه والغذاء
هو تعزيز الامن ليس لدوله واحده فحسبه
فنحنون نتحدث عن مشاركه المعلومات والقبض
على المجرمين واستغلال قوه الامن لجمع
العالم معا واعتقد بان هذه محافظات
ايجابيه جدا لجمع الدول معا بدلا من
تفرقتها لا شك ان المنتدى اليوم من
المنتديات الرائده خصوصا اليوم قاعد نتكلم
عن مشاركه اكثر من 100 دوله ااه 120 متحدث
اكثر من 4,500 حاضر همم تقريبا 30 جلسه
حواريه كلها تناقش جميع القضايا الحس
والمهمه في مجال الامن السبراني وكلها
تناقش اليوم على المجال العالمي بجميع
الافكار اللي تسب في مجال الامن السبراني
مساعد وزير الدفاع للشؤون التنفيذيه خالد
البياري قال ان الدول بدات تستفيد من
التجربه السعوديه في الامن السيبراني في
اشاره لتقدم السعوديه الى المركز الثاني
عالميا في الامن السيبراني بعد امريكا
اعتقد التجربه في المملكه ثريه جدا فيها
المجال همم مركزه العمل من خلال الهيئه
همم حقيقه كان نموذج همم مميز همم
وكثير من الدول اعتقد قاعده تتعلم من ال
ال ال ال التجربه المملكه همم
وجود وجود الهيئه وقدرتها على تنظيم
القطاع كان جدا مهم
يساهم هذا المنتدى عبر جلساته وشركاته في
ايجاد حلول لتامين الدول والقطاعات الخاصه
لانظمتها الالكترونيه
وحمايتها سيبرانيا
في ظل هجمات سيبرانيه متزايده لا تقل
خطورتها عن الحروب الواقعيه
من الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه من منتدى
الدوليه للامن السيبراني ينضم الينا
المهندس عبد الرحمن الحسن نائب محافظ
الهيئه الوطنيه للامن السيبراني
للاستراتيجيه والتعاون الدولي مهندس عبد
الرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض اولا لماذا المنتدى
الدولي للامن السبراني ما الحاجه له اليوم
في ظل وجود عدد كبير من المنتديات
الاقليميه همم التقنيه ودوليا ايضا
حياك الله اخوي نايف ومساء الخير لك
والاستاد المشاهدين الكرام طبعا للاجابه
على هذا السؤال هناك ثلاث عناصر اساسيه
ننظر لها العنصر الاول وانما يميز المنتدى
الدولي للامن السبراني هو وجود نظره
شموليه وواسعه على جميع القضايا المتعلقه
بالامن السيبراني وهذا نعتقد انه من خلاله
سيسهم في ملء وسد فراغ موجود على الساحه
العالميه لمعالجه القضايا الملحه والعاجره
في الامن السبراني النقطه الثانيه اخي
نايف ان المنتدى ليس فقط محصوره على
الجوانب التقنيه ذات الصله بالامن
السبراني وانما يتعدى هذا ليتناول قضايا
متعلقه بالجوانب الجيو السياسيه
والاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وكذلك الانسانيه
ويتضح اخي نايف همم هذا عندما ينظر الى
برنامج
الدوري للامن السبراني وكذلك الشعار الذي
تم تصميم له فنحن نتحدث عن شعار اعاده
الترتيبات في اعاده النظر في الترتيبات
السمرانيه العالميه وننظر في هذا الشعار
من خمسه محاور المحور الاول ينظر في
القضايا الجيوسيبرانيه وكذلك القضايا
الاقتصاديه متعلقه بالامن السبراني وايضا
مستقبل العمل السيبراني
وايضا الامن السبراني للجميع نقطه اخيره
فقط
ايضا عندما ننظر الى المتحدثين في هذا
المنتدى هناك 127 متحدث تقريبا اتوا من
مختلف التخصصات ومن مختلف الدول لمعالجه
وهمم النظر والتطرق بالموضوعات
الاستراتيجيه في الامن السبراني وهذا هو
حقيقه ما يميز المنتدى الدولي للامن
السبراني في وصف منصه عالميه تجمع الخبراء
في الامن السبراني بالحديث عن جمع الخبراء
عن هذه الجلسات عن النقاشات همم مع ختام
اليوم الثاني والاخير كيف وجدته ولمستوا
هذه النتائج للجلسات
للمخرجات لما تم في هذا المنتدى الدولي
ممتاز يمكن اخي نايف تلخيص هذه النتائج في
ثلاثه نقاط اساسيه النقطه الاولى ان هناك
اجماع دولي تقريبا من الخبراء المشاركين
في هذا المنتدى انه ل ل لبناء فضاء سبراني
امن وموثوق ان ان بناء الفضاء سبراني امن
وموثوق هو ركيزه اساسيه لتحقيق التنميه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه وايضا تحقيق ااه
الرخاء لمستقبل الانسان النقطه الاخرى اخي
نايف ان التعاون الدولي بين الدول
والمنظمات والقطاع الخاص هو ركيزه اساسيه
لبناء فضاء سبراني امن وموثوق يمكن النمو
والازدهار حول العالم
ايضا استشعرنا اخي نايف اهميه همم وجود
منصه عالميه تجمع خبراء الامن السيبراني
وتنظر في القضايا الامن السبراني من بعد
استراتيجي مثل القضايا التي تطرق لها
المنتدى الدولي للامن السمراني هذا العام
سواء كانت قضايا سياسيه او اقتصاديه او
اجتماعيه او غيرها بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء
الله شكرا جزيلا لك انضمامك الينا في
نشرات الرابعه من المنتدى الدولي الى
الامن السيبراني المهندس عبد الرحمن الحسن
نائب محافظ للهيئه الوطنيه للامن
الاسبراني
للاستراجيه والتعاون الدولي شكرا جزيلا لك
اشترتنا مستمره وفيها ايضا
هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه تعلن عن ارتفاع
الانتاج الصناعي ب 15% خلال شهر
كشف تقرير حديث صادر عن بنتك السعوديه عن
تضاعف عدد شركات التقنيه الماليه في
السعوديه بنحو 15 ضعفا وذلك منذ 2018 كما
كشفت تقرير ايضا عن حجم استثمارات تصل الى
اربعه مليارات ريال وفي نظره تاريخيه
لتطور قطاع التقنيه الماليه في السعوديه
نجد بان نواته الاولى كانت عام
1990 عندما اطلقت وزاره الماليه خدمه مدى
وفي عام 99 اطلق المركزي السعودي خدمه
سداد في ما جاءت الانطلاقه الكبرى عام
2018 مع اطلاق مبادره تنتك السعوديه
استراتيجيه التقنيه الماليه مشاهدينا
والتي تعد الركيزه الرابعه لبرنامج تطوير
القطاع المالي الذي اطلق في عام 2017
تهدفه بحلول 20 30 الى خلقه 18,000 وظيفه
و50
هنا شركه تقنيه ماليه بالاضافه الى وصول
حجم مساهمه القطاع في الناتج المحلي الى
ثلاثه عشر وثلاثه من 10 مليار ريال وحول
انشطه التقنيه الماليه نجد بان نشاطي
تمويل الملكيه الجماعيه والتمويل الجماعي
العقاري
تستحوذان على الحصه الاكبر من حجم ناشطه
القطاع ب 29% لكل منهما فيما تشكل ادوات
الدين كما نشاهد 17%
و16% للمستثمر الالي
اعداد الشركات مشاهدينا لقطاع التقنيه
الماليه سجلت نموا كبيرا حيث كان عدد
الشركات للقطاع العام في 2018 10 شركات
فقط
لتتضاعف منذ ذلك لتصل اليوم الى
147 شركه في العام الحالي الشركات العامله
مشاهدينا اليوم في السعوديه تقعوا مقرراته
87% منها في السعوديه فيما تتوزع مقرات
المقرات على مقرراتها 13% الاخرى على دول
اخرى وحوله مجالات شركات التقنيه الماليه
في السعوديه
تستحوذ كما نشاهد شركات المدفوعات وصرف
العملات على النصيب الاكبر باثنين وخمسين
شركه فيما جاءت ثانيا شركاته حلول الاعمال
وتوفير المعلومات بس 26 شركه فيما جاء عدد
البنوك الرقميه في السعوديه
بثلاثه وحول معد نموه مجالات شركات القطاع
جاء مجال البنيه التحتيه الاعلى نموا كما
نشاهد ب 600 في المئه يليه مجال التمويل
الشخصي واداره الخزينه ب 100
و75% في مكان الاقل نمو المجال الاقراض
والتمويل
42% وحولها شركات التقنيه المسجله في
قاعده بيانات بنت بنتك السعوديه شكلت
الشركات في مرحله التشغيل الكامل ال 21%
في ما لا تزال 9% من الشركات في مرحله
تصريح البيئه التجريبيه اما مرحله الفكره
فتشكل النسبه الاكبر بسبعه
37% من الشركات وهو ما يعطي تصورا عن
القفزه الكبيره المنتظره لهذا القطاع في
السعوديه خلال السنوات القريبه القادمه
[موسيقى]
لليوم الثاني تتواصلوا فعاليات المنتدى
مسك العالمي بنسخته الثانيه والاضخم حيث
اشاهد التوقيع مذكره لتفاهم بين مؤسسات
الامير محمد بن سلمان الخيريه وعدد من
الشركات لدعم وتطوير المهارات والاساليب
الرياديه والقياديه للشباب من خلال
البرامج المقدمه وضمن المنتدى العالمي
ايضا جلسات حواريه تجمع 120 متحدثا من حول
العالم بالاضافه الى عدد من المناطق
التفاعليه الاثرائيه
من فعاليات منتدى مسك العلميه بالرياض
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد
الاحمد عبد الواحد مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في النشاط الرابع من الرياض عدد من
الاتفاقيات من المذكرات التفاهم الثنائيه
التي وقعت في هذا المنتدى العالمي لمسك
كيف يمكن ان تجملها لنا
من هذا المنتدى حيث تستمر الفعاليات في
المناطق المختلفه التي يضمها المنتدى
نتحدث عن المسرح الذي تستمر فيه فعاليات
المتحدثين حيث تحدث وزير الاقتصاد
بالاضافه الى عدد من المتحدثين من مختلف
دول العالم حول موضوعات همم مختلفه
ومتنوعه همم الاطار الذي وضعته المؤسسه
والعنوان الرئيسي جيل التغيير همم فيما
يتعلق هي الاتفاقيات ومذكرات التفاهم التي
وقعتها مؤسسه مسك مع عدد من الجهات يعني
جهات حكوميه وكذلك حتى القطاع الخاص وكذلك
همم يعني جهات تعتني بالشباب وهمم اضافه
الى عدد من همم يعني الجهاد في القطاع
الثالث نريد ان نتعرف اكثر على همم تفاصيل
ما حدث خلال ايام هذا المنتدى ينضم الينا
الاستاذ ناصر المطيري وهو مدير عام مسك
المهارات اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ ناصر نريد
ان نعرف ابتداء ان همم ما المختلف في هذه
النسخه من المنتدى شكرا لكم استضافه اليوم
احنا نحتفل بالنسخه الاضخم والنسخه
السادسه من منتدى مسك العالمي اا هذه
النسخه همم تتميز اولا بانها تتوافق مع
احتفالات المؤسسه بمرور عشر سنوات على
انشائيها كذلك ليميز هل النسخه عنوان
المنتدى هذا العام هو وزير التغيير جيل
التغيير وربط الاجيال مختلفه لمناقشه
تحديات يتواجه الشباب محليا وعالميا عبر
اعطاء المنصه الرئيسيه المنتدى وتقديم
نخبه من الخبراء ونفكرين وادي الاعمال
لتبادل الخبرات والتحديات الواجهات الشباب
كذلك يميز المنتدى هذه العام تواجد كمان
مساحات تفاعليه تمثل برامج المؤسسه
المختلفه مثلا بمساراتها الاربعه مسك
القاده والرياده ومسك المهارات ومسك
المجتمع كذلك ايضا تواجد همم مسارات
التواجد زم لاصحاب المصلحه في المؤسسات
استاذ ناصر يعني هناك عده مذكرات تفاهم ثم
توقيعها لو تجمل لنا يعني ابرز المذكرات
هذه يعني فيما همم وقعتم كذلك مذكره تفاهم
مع جهات حكوميه صحيح مذكرات التفاهم اللي
وقعناها في المنتدى
مذكرات تفاهم مع جهات حكوميه قطاع خاص
وكذلك القطاع غير الربحي المحور حول
تضافروا الجهود والمواهمه والبناء على ال-
ال- ال- ما تم عملوا سابقا سواء من خلال
المسك او من خلال اصحاب المصلحه الشركات
في تقديمها البرامج بما يؤثر او يخدم في
نهايه المطاف المستفيدين من برامج المؤسسه
بشكل عام وقناه اتفاقيات مع مركز قطاع
الربحي كذلك اتفاقيات مع وزاره الخارجيه
وقائنات مع جهات في القطاع
الاعمال كذلك مع انت همم دوليه عالميه
تتيح الوصول الرواد الاعمال عالميا باذن
الله
جهات مختلفه شاركتكم اليوم في المنتدى في
الحضور سواء في المعرض او حتى على المسرح
للحديث حول موضوعات مختلفه ما هي ابرز
الموضوعات المختلفه للتناقشتها زي ما تفضل
لك احنا عندنا اليوم حين مثلا نشوف
ميداليزر وهو لقاء القائد وهنا يتكلم كل
قائد يعطي الشباب السعودي لما عن تجربه
الشخصيه ويقودهم الى التفكير انه يشد
الظروف المستفاده من التجربه عندنا في
الزاويه الاخرى همم مراجعه السيره الذاتيه
وهو كذلك يتحدث عن كثافه السيره الذاتيه
وتطويرها بمساحه طلاب الجامعات على تجاوز
كل عقبات يتواجهها شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ
ناصر المطيري على كل هذه التفاصيل التي
زودتنا بها كما تشاهدنا هذه هي ابرز يعني
تحديثات منتدى مسك العالمي الذي يغلق
ابوابه اليوم بعد يعني ساعات من الان
اشكرك شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اصدرت هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه نتائج مؤشر
الانتاج الصناعي لشهر سبتمبر من العام
الحالي اظهرت النتائج ارتفاع المؤشر لشهر
سبتمبر بنسبه 15% مقارنه بالشهر المماثل
من العام الماضي وجاء هذا الارتفاع نتيجه
نشاط التعدين واستغلال المحاجر بنسبه 14%
كما ارتفع نشاط صناعه التحويليه لذات
الشهر بنسبه 22% فيما اظهر نشاط وامدادات
الكهرباء والغاز ارتفاعا ايضا بنسبه 5%
مقارنه بشهر اغسطس من العام الحالي
استعرضا فيلم العربيه الوثائقي الوعد
الاخضر مبادرات السعوديه الخاصه بالمناخ
بالاضافه الى خطتها لمواجهه ازماته
الوثائقيه والذي عرضته العربيه بالتزامن
مع انطلاق مؤتمر الاطراف حول المناخ كوب
توني 7 في شرم الشيخ بمصر استعرضه اراء
مختصين وعلماء في مجال المناخ كما بحثت
تهديدات المناخيه مثل الاحتباس الحراري
ينضم الينا من دبي
في قناه العربيه
عقيل مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
دائما كل فيلم وثائقي يبدا همم فكره وبعد
ذلك الفكره تتحول الى الرؤيا الرؤيه ايضا
تنفذ اريد السؤال هنا عن الفكره كيف بدات
وكم استغرق العمل ايضا على هذا الفيلم
اهلا وسهلا بك بك نايف اتفق معاك في
الفكره اللي اللي طرحتها تعرف نايف ان
الحديث حول
التغير المناخ
ومشاريع الطاقه المتجدده عالميا اصبح واحد
من المواضيع الحيويه اللي تضل تسمع عنها
كل يوم على المستوى المحلي او على المستوى
العالمي مشاريع الطاقه المتجدده او محور
الطاقه المتجدده استحود على جزء من رؤيه
20 30 في السعوديه همم كان في التزامات
السعوديه تجاه هذا هذا المحور همم السنه
الماضيه نايف كان في همم حديث لوزير
الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان في واحد من اجتماعات اوبريك همم
حديث وزير الطاقه السعودي في هذا الاجتماع
كان هو همم شراره الفكره بالنسبه لي انا
كمعدد برامج للعمل او للبحث في عمل همم
وثائقي بخصوص هذا الموضوع
الماضيه همم وزير الطاقه السعودي قال انه
على العالم ان ينظر لنا بطريقه مختلفه من
السعوديه لم تعد فقط بلد همم يصدر الطاقه
البتروليه او الوقود الاحفوري فقط الى الى
العالم السعوديه سوف تكون في مقدمه الدول
اللي تصدر الطاقه بجميع اشكالها وجميع
انواعها ممتاز المستقبل القريب وان على
العالم القبول بهذه الحقيقه
التصريح هذا طرح في باريس انه بالضبط شو
هي المشاريع اللي قاعد يصير على الارض همم
كيف وكيف يمشي العمل عليها في السعوديه
حاليا طيب او حالي بمرحله انتقاليه حقيقيه
تعيش تعيشها السعوديه في هذه الممتاز
العقيل بعين الصحفي انت تنقلت في عدد من
المواقع المهمه في هذه المشاريع ربما
المشاريع الموجوده من قبل المشاريع الطاقه
المتجدده وسريعه الجديده مناطق ربما لم
يصل اليها
صحفيين حتى الان ما الذي لفت انتباهك
وتعتقد بانه همم بشيء لم يسبق لاحد ان
يطلع عليه او حتى يكتب عنا او ان ينقل
ايضا حتى للمشاهدين
قال يعني في الحقيقه لما كنت انزل على
الارض لاماكن المشاريع كان في بالي ثلاثه
او اربع محاور كنت همم ابحث همم على اجوبه
همم بخصوصها الفكره الاولى الصناعه
الجديده اللي راح توصل للمنطقه همم هذه
كيف راح يستقبلها اهل همم المنطقه همم من
راح يشغل هذه المشاريع من راح يمدها
بالخدمات همم المسانده ويعمل على تطويرها
مع الوقت همم كل منطقه كنا نوصل لها نايف
كنت لاحظ ان اهل المنطقه نفسهم او ابناء
المنطقه هم الذين يقومون بتشغيل همم هذه
المشاريع وادارتها وكثيره
الى عدنان
صحيح صحيح يعني
في في سكاكا مثلا مشروع الطاقه الشمسيه
كامل للفريق اللي يشغل محطه الطاقه
الشمسيه ويديرها هو فريق سعودي من اهل
الجوف قامت الشركه المطوره للمشروع هذا
بتدريب هم للعمل في هذا في هذا المشروع
نفس الشيء بالنسبه لمحطه تحليه المياه في
في رابغ في عندك عاملين العامل الاول
نوعيه التعليم اللي حصل عليها همم ابناء
المناطق السعوديه سواء داخل السعوديه او
خارجها اهلتهم ان هم ممكن انه همم
يستقبلون مثل هذه المشاريع ويشغلونها على
وجه السرعه بكفاء همم عاليه النقطه
الثانيه اللي فتحتها انتباهي في هذا
المشاريع نايف انه هذه المشاريع تضمن همم
التنميه التي تمتد لكل المناطق السعوديه
وما تنحصر في مناطق همم معينه همم همم
الفكره الثالثه اللي نفتت انتباهي نايف
انه المشاريع اللي تم همم انشاها وتشغيلها
حاليا هي قصص همم نجاح حققت ارقام همم
جيده جدا
وتنبا بمستقبل افضل لبقيه المشاريع
القادمه من خلال السنوات همم الجايه يعني
في مجال تحليه المياه همم السعوديه
تدريجيا تنتقل من محطات التحليه همم
التقليديه الى محطات همم التحليه بالتناضح
العكسي همم خلال السنه الماضيه همم هذه
المحطات تفضلت من همم اطلاق الكربون
بحوالي 28 مليون طن من الكربون في الهواء
هذه همم
حتى 20 و30 انا انا اشكرك همم جزيل الشكر
ادعوا طبعا كل همم من شاهد الرابعه ان
نتابع هذا الفيلم الوعد الاخضر هو موجود
على حساب قناه العربيه في يوتيوب شكرا
جزيلا همم لك من دبي على الجيل بو 50
برامج في قناه العربيه
كشفت وزاره الحج والعمره عن استفاده
المعتمرين والزائرين من اكثر من 2700
منشاه مقدمه للخدمات الصحيه في مدن ومناطق
السعوديه خلال موسم العمره القادمه
151 مستشفى خدماتها بالاضافه الى
773 مركزا صحيا ونحو 1800 مختبر طبي
والصيدليه في جميع المناطق وذلك برنامج
التامين على المعتمرين القادمين من الخارج
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
رئيس هيئه الترفيه في السعوديه يعلن بدء
التحضير لموسم الجديد من مسلسل طاش ما طاش
على شاشه ام بي سي
حياكم الله من جديد بعد مضيء 11 عاما على
اخر اجزاء المسلسل السعودي الاشهر طاش ما
طاش اعلن رئيسه هيئه الترفيه السعوديه
تركي ال الشيخ عن عوده المسلسل وذلك في
تغريده له عبر حسابه الرسمي على تويتر
مشيرا الى ان العمل سيكون بدعم من هيئه
الترفيه وسيعرض على قناه ام بي سي في
رمضان المقبل
تقدموا منصه حاضرين العديد من الخدمات
والمعلومات الارشاديه لمشجع الكاس العالم
القادمين عبر السعوديه وذلك بشراكه بين
عده وزارات وهيئه حكوميه لتقديم تجربه
ثريه وممتعه للمشجعين والزوار الراغبين
باكتشافي معالم السعوديه السياحيه سمير
عبد الرحمن العصيمي مع التفاصيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حاضرين منصه جديده اطلقتها السعوديه قبيلا
انطلاق كاس العالم لنتعرف على ملامح هذه
المنصه
[موسيقى]
ما هي الجهات الحكوميه المشاركه في هذه
المنصه الهيئه السعوديه للسياحه بالاضافه
الى وزارات الرياضه والداخليه والاعلام
الى جانب وزاره النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه
وايضا تشارك الهيئه العامه للنقل وهيئه
الزكاه والضريبه والجمارك هيئه الطيران
المدني هي الاخرى تشارك في هذه المنصه
برفقه شركه مطارات القابضه
[موسيقى]
الى ماذا تهدف هذه المنصه على راسي
اولوياتها تيسير وتسهيل تجربه المواطن
والمقيم والزائر الراغبين بحضور مباريات
كاس العالم والعوده الى السعوديه حاضرين
تهدف الى توفير المعلومات الارشاديه
وايضا الخدمات لضمان تقديم تجربه ثريه
وسلسه وممتعه بجماهير كاس العالم
المنصات تهدف الى التعريف بمعالم السعوديه
السياحيه ووجهاتها المتنوعه للراغبين
بزياره البلاد خلال كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
مطارات الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في جده
والملك خالد الدولي في الرياض ومطار الملك
فهد الدولي في الدمام الذي نحن فيه الان
ستكون على اهبه الاستعداد لاستقبال مشجعين
كاس العالم وذلك عبر عده اجراءات وتسهيلات
ودعم اللوجستي للمسافرين عبر توفير رحلات
لنقل المشجعين بالطائرات يوميا هذه
الرحلات اليوميه التردديه تصل الى مطار
الدوحه الدولي خدمه النقل الترددي
بالحافلات الى هذه المطارات متوفره مجانا
مواقف السيارات حاضره في مواقع خدمات
النقل في الحافلات احضر شنطتك الصغيره
واستمتع بحضور مباريات كاس العالم
في حاله وجود اي استفسارات او حاله طارئه
فقط عليك زياره موقع هير فور يو دوت اس اي
او التواصل مع المركز الوطني للعمليات
الامنيه عبر الرقم
911 عبد الرحمن العصيمي من المنطقه
الشرقيه العربيه
[تصفيق]
خلال هذه الايام تختفي الزواحف والعقارب
وهذا دليل على بدايه البلد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
علاقه الشجر والبشر والحشر بالمناخ علاقه
تلازميه وعلىماتها يستدل بها على المواسم
فاختفاء الزواحف دليل على بدايه البرد
وتطليع النخيل وظهور الحشرات دليل على
بدايه الربيع اذا طلعت البرنيه اطلع
بالحوش بدون بطانيه وكثره الذباب سنه
الربيعيه وكثره الجراد سنه مجذبه اللهم
اجعلها سنه ضباب ولا تجعلها سنه تجراد
وظهور الوزغ والحيايا والعقارب والثعابين
وجميع الهوام السامه دليل على بدايه الحرب
والوزق الرقه على ذلها تطعم الحياه في
الجحر والخنفس والاسود من نجله موده
العقرب
في السري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام تختفي الزواحف والعقارب
والثعابين وجميع الهوام السامه وهذا دليل
على بدايه البوادر الشتويه وتظل مختبئه
وكامنه في جحورها لمده ثلاثه شهور تقريبا
ولا تطلع وتظهر
بدايه البوادر الصيفيه واول ما يختفي منها
المسن واول ما يظهر منها الصغير لا تامن
العقرب ولا تامن الداب السم واحد لها رجاء
في متونك يا جاهل الدنيا ودورات الاسباب
اعرف ترى من خان غيرك
يخونك
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
استمرار وتقدم الجمهوريين على حساب
الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب وتوقعاتهم
بحسم سباق الليله
امين عام الناتو يقولوا ان القوات الروسيه
تتعرض لضغوطها الى في اوكرانيا
وازاله الحج والعمره تكشف عن اكثر من 2700
انشات صحيه في مختلف المدن ضمن برنامج
التامين على المعتمرين
هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه تعلن عن ارتفاع
الانتاج الصناعي ب 15% خلال الشهر
رئيس هيئه الترفيه في السعوديه يعلن وبدات
تحضير لموسم الجديد 18 على شاشه ام بي سي
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]